[Musique]
si les nazis ont un lien,
nous avons une relation compliquée avec
les armes nucléaires, notre peur des flux et
reflux mais la menace ne disparaît jamais
d'une manière définitivement inscrite dans le principe. J'ai utilisé ce
moment incroyable du
projet Manhattan, ce moment où les scientifiques
ont réalisé  qu'ils ne pouvaient pas éliminer
la possibilité que lorsqu'ils déclencheraient
le test Trinity, ils déclencheraient une
réaction en chaîne qui détruirait le
monde, alors l'Esprit d'Oppenheimer s'est assis sur le
locataire d'une manière particulière et Rob
Pattinson, lorsque nous avons terminé, m'a offert comme
cadeau de rap  un livre de discours
qu'Oppenheimer a prononcé dans les années 1950 et
la lecture de ces discours qui parlent tous
de quelqu'un d'une grande intelligence essayant
d'accepter les conséquences
de ce qu'il a mis au monde
m'a définitivement rapproché de
quelque chose auquel je jouais  avec et
en y réfléchissant pendant de nombreuses années, je pense que l'
histoire d'Oppenheimer est l'une des plus
dramatiques que j'ai jamais rencontrées,
mais je pense vraiment que c'est ce qui
a fait de cela une réalité pratique lorsque je
lisais euh Kai Bird et Marta Insurance
American Prometheus qui  est un
livre merveilleusement documenté, il a fallu 25
ans pour que
[Musique]
tu cries en quelque sorte de joie ouais tu
sautes de haut en bas définitivement et puis tu
sprintes pour le rencontrer même s'il n'est pas
prêt pour toi tu cours juste, je veux dire, j'étais juste
tellement excité, tellement
excité, c'est un peu
honoré, je ne sais pas,
j'étais tellement excité quand il m'appelait, je le
contactais périodiquement au fil des
ans, comme si tout
fonctionnait vraiment, je le ferais pas cher, euh ouais, fais-le pas
cher, je dirai oui.  Je suis disponible,
je suis disponible pour publier ça, je
suis disponible et puis il m'a dit, perds
mon numéro, tu es l'homme qui leur a donné
le pouvoir de se détruire, il n'y
a rien de vraiment plus effrayant
que l'énergie atomique, les armes atomiques, les
armes nucléaires telles qu'elles se sont développées.  et donc, cependant,
vous citez des histoires passionnantes, positives et
intéressantes et les
personnages qui l'entourent et il y en a, il y
a des choses vraiment amusantes, des
choses vraiment excitantes qui se passent, mais
en dessous, il y a
ce changement qu'ils apportent  le
monde qui est terrifiant et qui a changé la
vie sur Terre de manière irrévocable et qui
hante donc le film d'une manière. J'ai trouvé
frappant lorsque nous avons commencé à montrer
le film aux gens que vous sachiez clairement
que cet élément pèse lourdement sur le film,
peut-être aussi à cause de  le
climat politique actuel aussi, vous ne pouvez
jamais savoir dans quel monde vous
savez que votre film va être diffusé
lorsque j'ai abordé ce sujet. J'ai eu une
conversation avec un de mes fils adolescents
au début, je lui ai dit ce que j'étais.  Je travaille
sur ce sujet et il m'a en fait dit : est-ce que
quelqu'un s'inquiète vraiment à ce sujet,
vous savez, c'est que c'est vraiment un sujet de
préoccupation pour les gens deux ans plus tard, il ne
pose pas cette question, personne ne pose
cette question malheureusement de la
manière la plus horrible, notre
préoccupation justifiée concernant le nucléaire  les armes
sont revenues et nous avons une
relation compliquée avec
les armes nucléaires notre peur que les flux et reflux mais
la menace ne disparaît jamais nous
choisissons simplement de ne pas y penser parfois
euh encore une fois, c'est au premier plan de la
pensée des gens,
je suppose mais  ça ne ressemblait pas à une
dictature ou quoi que ce soit, je pense qu'il
veut juste que tout le monde soit concentré et il a
raison parce qu'en fin de compte, quand
il y a des gens qui s'en prennent à leur
caravane et qu'ils envoient des SMS et aiment que
c'est juste différent  ça
ralentit les choses ça crée plus de chaos il bouge
si vite qu'il n'y a pas de temps pour un je n'ai pas
eu le temps je n'ai pas eu le temps de passer un
appel comme s'il n'y en avait pas tu sais je le ferais
j'appellerais à la maison au début
de ma journée, puis à la fin de la journée,
mais comme pendant la journée, vous alliez vraiment
vite et la production a
beaucoup d'élan et Chris conduit très
fort parce que vous en faites tellement plus
euh quand vous quand vous utilisez  cette
approche, je pense à Spielberg et
Soderberg ainsi que vous savez, les gens
ont dit oh il n'y a pas, il n'y a pas de
chaises sur le plateau de Steven Soderberg et j'y
vais, je n'y ai jamais pensé mais c'est
probablement vrai ouais, il n'y a pas de
chaises sur les plateaux de Steven mais  tu pouvais te
percher dessus, c'était amusant ouais parce que tu
sais ce que j'ai trouvé dans ce film qui
m'a fait rire au fil du
film à mesure que je vieillis et que de plus
en plus de membres de l'équipe de prothèses ont
commencé à m'offrir une boîte Apple comme s'ils
étaient inquiets  à propos de moi et j'étais
comme les gars, j'ai toujours le même âge que moi,
j'ai l'air horrible mais je peux le supporter, tu sais,
c'est tellement drôle mais c'est une façon vraiment amusante
de travailler parce que toi, parce que tout le monde,
tout le monde ressent cet élan, ouais,
tu es fatigué à la  en fin de compte, ce que
vous devriez être,
je veux dire, il y a certainement un lien dans les
récits euh et et d'une manière dont
vous utilisez la couleur et le noir et
blanc pour essayer d'orienter l'histoire dans le
récit, vous savez, Memento avait un très
complexe  euh, chronologie, nous avons utilisé la couleur en
noir et blanc pour essayer d'indiquer aux
gens comment cela fonctionnait chez
Oppenheimer, nous avons deux façons très différentes
de regarder son histoire, les
séquences de couleurs sont totalement subjectives,
tout est de son point de vue et c'est
le  la majeure partie du film mais il y a
ces scènes en noir et blanc et j'utilise
le noir et blanc pour simplement changer
le sentiment du public sur les scènes,
ils sont plus objectifs, ils sont vraiment
du
point de vue du personnage de Robert Downey Jr. Lewis Strauss, le
personnage qu'il  joue et c'est donc le
contraste de ces choses tout au long du
film qui vous donne, je pense, une
compréhension plus tridimensionnelle de l'
histoire d'Oppenheimer.
Vous avez ces événements et nous l'avons fait pendant le
tournage du test de la trilogie parce que je
ne voulais pas utiliser CG.  nous faisions des
événements explosifs à très grande échelle et il
y a toujours une tension énorme, vous
savez que vous êtes dans le désert la nuit,
ces choses doivent être faites en toute sécurité et
avec soin, donc il y a beaucoup de procédures, il y
a beaucoup de protocoles de sécurité comme
ils l'avaient dans le  Test Trinity et donc je
pense que cela a mis tout le monde dans le bon
état d'esprit, en fait, cela nous a donné un tout
petit avant-goût très trivial de ce que ça a dû
être d'être là ce soir-là
ouais, je lui disais comme je l'ai dit, il
suffit de le mémoriser.  pour le tu
sais pour le pour les deux minutes
que tu le fais tu sais et puis et euh
et tu l'oublieras tu sais complètement
et tu n'as pas besoin de savoir ce que cela signifie
tu es aussi long que ton  le
conseiller technique l'examine et dit ça
ressemble à de la physique alors tout va bien j'ai
hâte de le voir je suis ravi de le
voir et j'y vais c'est un super
week-end pour les cinéphiles n'est-ce pas
deux grands réalisateurs qui sortent avec de grands
films très différents et vous savez, on m'a
d'abord posé des questions à ce sujet parce que quelqu'un
a dit bien, qu'est-ce que tu fais, j'ai dit bien, Ben
et moi, en grandissant, nous allions voir deux films
chaque week-end, comme aller voir deux films qu'il venait de
montrer  moi quelque chose que ça vient de dire
AMC vient d'annoncer un grand nombre de
billets de personnes qui vont pour la
double affiche et c'est juste génial on
adore ça, bon pour notre business merci merci
beaucoup merci merci
étranger
[Musique]